[Music]
so here in this video we will discuss 20
very important things that you might
have missed in the recently released
thor love and thunder teaser firstly we
start by seeing a flashback of thor
running through the woods of asgard
first as a child reflecting on his
thoughts about being carefree and having
no responsibilities then quickly shifts
into his teenage self with the classic
jack kirby costume from thor comics
issue number one we then see him in his
adult stage of life adoring the infinity
saga costume and lastly walking by the
flames in his ravager costume that he
wears while fighting alongside the
guardians of the galaxy
so this scene quickly shifts into him
finding solitude in a hillside under a
tree on a planet with maybe two or three
suns he plants the handle of
stormbreaker on the soil under that tree
where he meditates
being kind of ironic since he would
battle again later on this scene is in
connection with the latter one where we
see him alongside the guardians of the
galaxy and instead of charging into
battle he goes the opposite direction
kind of tired of all the fights i'm
probably guessing that he would fly
somewhere and meditate and only join
again the battle later on after knowing
that doing nothing would not help anyone
dressed in 80s retro clothing
and one of peter quill's jackets with
the sleeves ripped off
so then we see thor shedding his weight
i'm kind of thinking this would be the
opening parts of the movie as the prior
scenes are him in his fit form after all
those curves have left that body
during that batman rope exercise we can
see him wearing a cap with the world's
strongest avenger written on it which
shows his nostalgia on
not being a part of the avengers anymore
since his friends have died or have
retired what is surprising is that we
can see him using the chains of a dead
king kong
just kidding that's not kong but i'm
betting that's one of marvel's dead ape
gods either gekre or hanuman this is the
first dead god to be seen in the teaser
signifying gore the god butcher has
already started his killing spree
so if we look closely while fighting
with the goddess of the galaxy we can
see peter quill drags groot
rocket nebula and crackling
in that team but gamora is missing so
i'm pretty sure after end game this new
version of gamora from 2014 still
haven't met peter quill of fallen for
him and bonded with the other members so
she's still finding her way around
things and won't be joining the
guardians until volume 3.
we see them dropping off thor and gork
and zakar since after the revolution
during ragnarok the grand master would
have been overthrown and these two bros
would like to see what's happening there
after all thor has no plans whatsoever
as of that time
so on one of his battles or during one
of his travels he meets up with pirates
and kind of kisses one
but then in the background there is a
dead kraken whether it's just a creature
being fished out for food or the kraken
was one of the gods being killed by god
the butcher is still unknown hopefully
it's the latter reason and i'm thinking
this is where thor would get a boat for
his later travels to earth and olympus
you know using the goats or the bifrost
from stormbreaker
so in the next scene in an amazing sight
we see the mystical two goats of thor
who usually pulls his chariots into
battle well in myths
they are to nasher antutu grinder now
pulling a flying longboard with thor
cork and valkyrie on it the boat does
have a neon sign on it
when you zoom you will see the upper
part of the cocktails and dreams sign
written on it the same one from the tom
cruise movie cocktail i'm pretty sure
that thor will later use stormbreaker at
least the bifrost power of stormbreaker
to power the ship and let it travel
across the universe in that same scene
we can see thor in a new costume slash
armor and that is reminiscent of the
ruined king thor's battle gear with an
80s retro vibe with it
we then jump into another scene we see
an amazing sight of olympus which looks
to be kind of floating in mid-air
olympus like asgard seems to be a mega
structure in space and time home to a
race of near immortal beings being
regarded as gods by humans so these are
the greek gods so whether it was thor or
gaul the god butcher who was arriving
there is still unknown one thing we are
curious about is the kind of cosmic
magic that is present in olympus and
used by zeus which would bring up the
question about the relations between
them with the eternals if zeus and the
other gods are really just eternals or
whether they are taught by them to
harness the same type of energy
so after the greek gods we now come to a
scene of a gigantic monster creature who
is seemingly dead
that giant isn't a kaiju or a feral
creature it's one of the gods that is
killed by gore that giant is called
falgar the behemoth he was a friend of
thor or at least an acquaintance and was
the champion god of the tournament of
immortals so being such a strong entity
seeing him dead would have instilled
caution and fear onto the minor thor
it would be here that thor would start
to take things more seriously regarding
gore the god butcher and his killing
spree across the universe
okay so now let's take a quick look at
the new asgard
which has now become a tourist
attraction site
and valkyrie is now the queen or king of
new asgard of the asgardians she is
sitting there in a meeting with
representatives of many countries like
the united states china maybe wakanda
discussing renewable energy and possibly
how the asgardians would now contribute
to the planet
to planet earth in terms of technology
and other sciences
meek remembered that alien would cork
that alien insect is now working under
her and she seems to be bored as hell
being the leader of the asgardians which
would probably lead her to join thor
later in the storyline in an adventure
to fight against the god of the god
butcher
the teaser has many revealing scenes but
they all seem to be jumbled up and not
in a chronological order the scene where
peter quill states that if you ever feel
lost just look at the eyes of the people
you love
would have been with the earlier scenes
like when they left thor and cork in
zakar so this scene also shows that
peter quill has now matured more into
the role of a leader of the guardians
and thor has kind of developed kind of a
kinship with him or at least on the side
of thor
as he tries to look into star-lord's
eyes after hearing those words yeah i'm
pretty sure that this is the scene where
the guardians say farewell to thor and
gork
in zakar
now lastly we see a reforged milner
being wielded by jain as the mighty thor
this has been teased quite a lot and
rumored and now it's a reality now those
broken pieces of myanmar in new asgard
which were left there during hella's
release from nilfiam are still there
even though they were shattered into
many pieces
the enchantment is still intact and no
one would be able to lift them to
another place so i'm pretty sure jane
would be arriving a new asgard somewhere
in the storyline of the movie
and somehow the ruins of myanmar would
reform into the hammer and choose jane
as the worthy bearer thus transforming
her into the mighty thor and granting
her the powers of thor
this also means that thor would have
transcended his previous role as the
fighter thor and would now become the
rune king thor a more powerful version
so what are we still missing here oh the
reveal of god the god butcher
well we already know that christian bale
is going to be the alien god killer we
are still curious about how this mcu
iteration is going to look like so even
though we haven't seen gaul in this
trailer his actions are pretty evident
and when he comes out
can you guess what will be along with
him uh i mean coming out along with him
a symbiote not just any regular one but
it's gonna be the debut of the all-black
the necrosword officially that is not
regarding the heller's neck resorts as
the all black symbiotes
so yeah gaw the god butcher and all
black anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and smash that bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel
till the next one take care fam